MOMENT AS WELL FROM KYRIE
IRVING.
MEGHAN TRIPLETT STANDING BY
WITH KYRIE.
KYRIE, THE GAME WAS TIED UP
WITH OVER A MINUTE LEFT TO
PLAY.
WHAT DID IT TAKE TO CLOSE OUT
THIS GAME?
>> TOOK NOT BEING SOFT,
HONESTLY.
COMING OUT TOO SOFT SOMETIMES
AND BASKETBALL'S MEANT TO BE
PLAYED AT A HIGH LEVEL, HIGH
LEVEL INTENSITY.
OUR FANS WILL LET US KNOW IF
WE ARE NOT PLAYING HARD ENOUGH
SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
JUST MAKES US WANT TO GO
HARDER.
WE WANT TO TAKE THIS TO A
CHAMPIONSHIP RUN, THAT
INCLUDES DOING EVERYTHING
EVERY POSSESSION.
>> 30 POINTS, SEVEN ASSISTS,
11-24 FROM THE FIELD.
WHAT ALLOWED YOU TO BE SO
SUCCESSFUL.
>> SOUNDS LIKE KOBE NUMBERS
RIGHT THERE.